so welcome and thank you all so much for
coming out this morning and no worries
if you're just like drinking coffee and
like vibing through this this is very
much a like vibe accepting talk
um so yeah as you mentioned i'm a
professor at northwestern but i really
identify as a person who kind of walks
between fields
i'm not an expert in most of the fields
that i walk between but i'm able to kind
of carry knowledge from one field to
another
so i'm going to definitely be talking
about a lot of things today that i am
not an expect like an expert or even
particularly proficient in but i think
that the ideas are kind of neat to to
cross to cross-pollinate with
so yeah where are we in this talk um so
this is my my graph of strange loop um
these are two talks that i saw yesterday
um our keynote in the morning was very
loop uh but not very strange um dancing
with myself was both very strange and
very loop um so this talk today will be
very strange not terribly loop
so yeah
what is this talk about this talk is
about
knowing things
and building programs
it's also about how we know things by
building programs
and sometimes how we know things by
building programming languages
and sometimes how we know things just by
building languages themselves
and the best way to do that is with our
friends and so kind of talking about
this as a social activity that we do
together as a community
i'll talk about this image over on the
right later
so yeah part one this is the like semi
autobiographical part
when you accidentally a language
it's a little bit about me this is my
first time at strange loop i'm super
excited to be here uh especially up on
the podium
and in in march 3rd of 2020 um i gave a
keynote at bang bang conwest if y'all
haven't been to bang bang con they're
very relevant to this conference and we
definitely had 100 unmasked people in an
auditorium
and we were trying to be very coveted
safe so instead of shaking hands we
bumped feet so that was kind of the
level of like where we were in march
2020. that was the last time i was at a
conference
so that was a keynote this is a keynote
and it has been a short 577 days of no
conferencing in between those although
we did lots of online conferencing which
is great um if you want to see that
unhinged keynote if you're enjoying this
unhinged keynote you can also watch the
one about muppets
um i haven't also gotten to show my cat
at this conference yet so far which is
rare for a conference in 2021 says my
cat ishar
um so about me um i'm a maker of many
interesting things so i made a language
called treasury that i'll be talking to
you about today
but i also do like a lot of generative
art there was a generative art workshop
earlier this week
where apparently i got a call out
but i do a lot of stuff with like p5
with javascript with canvas i've gotten
really into doing some kind of fun
machine learned
things with being able to detect where
your face is and then making cool
generative masks that play with you
i also do a ton of outreach stuff so i'm
like teaching is a fun tool in my bag
that i do like i'm teaching for
northwestern it's nice they give me
healthcare and they pay me really quite
well
but i'll always just like continue
teaching wherever i am
and so as part of that i do a lot of
like ai outreach so i have a motto that
is bringing ai to the people that ai
doesn't deserve
so i consider again myself canada as a
carrier of knowledge
and as a carrier of knowledge you often
have to kind of translate to the groups
that you're going to so i have a lot of
different tools for different audiences
the one at the bottom is i recently gave
a workshop to the
an ai workshop to the theater department
where we were in fact writing real ai we
were in fact interacting with real ai
but they could still do that as like
kind of
advanced theater professional like for
professionals and so this was like how i
described ai to them
um the thing up at the top i'm teaching
a machine learning class and this was me
attempting to make a map of what machine
learning is for my undergraduate
students in cs so you talk to different
people in different ways so i do a lot
of outreach stuff so see me later if
you'd like to get some of my zines or
buttons or stickers or things
but yeah like as part of that job i
really spend a lot of time thinking like
okay you know i can search the wikipedia
definition of something but i need to be
able to communicate to a person who's
not in that field what that thing really
is like and for them like what is this
thing what role is this thing going to
play in your life how do i interact with
this thing who is this thing
um but first a little bit about tracery
so tracery this is a language that i
made um
it's a super and i really made it kind
of accidentally for a class project so
the history of tracery i think i've got
yeah so the class project was uh i had a
class project that was supposed to be a
pencil and paper assignment and i did it
in javascript instead um and i wanted to
describe a roman if anybody's seen a
funny thing happen on the way to the
forum
that's actually based on actual roman
plays um of these sort like and
he was in love with a maid who it turned
out was actually a senator who was
secretly disguised as twins and then it
was his sister
so that kind of like fractal
storytelling i was trying to describe
that and i uploaded it and
a lot of people started making really
awesome tools for it but the actual
language itself is like next to trivial
i was able to write it when i was just
getting started in javascript and the
thing is basically
what tracer is you have this json object
over to the left
you can see you have it's
a context free grammar and you have some
terminal names and then you have or you
have some symbol names and you have some
possible terminals for them and you can
see in a couple of these let's see yeah
so this is the one that i made to uh
generate strange loop greetings um you
have like activity doing like hashtag
doing things to hashtag program
adjective
programs preventing
hackers from hashtag activity so you've
got like a recursive one in there
so this is like fairly straightforward
you're just going to recursively expand
that text and then look up the symbols
that are in that text
i've successfully taught this to third
graders so hopefully y'all will be
catching up on it easily enough
and that gives you kind of like an
interesting possibility space
of in a very small grammar um saying
hello to strange loop and asking you
what you did what you did last night
like
debunking functional board games and
preventing hackers from programming
insecure programming languages
um so yeah there's a whole bunch of
stuff that's been made with tracery
this was a thing that i made with
tracery although this is running on
cheap bots done quick which is uh cheap
spin quick is a hosting site so open
source stories um i open source tracery
um
yeah i
open sourced it free as in mattress if
you all are familiar with the term
freeze friezan beer frias and speech for
open source there are a couple of other
options including free as in mattress
where this is abandoned it's probably
full of bugs but you're welcome to take
it if it's like if it's useful to you
there's freezing piano where like you're
welcome to take this thing it's probably
extremely valuable but there's no way
you're actually going to get it set up
and free as in puppy where this is a
wonderful thing that is given to you
free and it is going to be a lifetime of
work
so different kinds of free and free
software
tracer was definitely free as in
mattress so i uploaded it a person in
london called v buckingham
made this really cool tool such that um
if you paste in your little json into
their site
and you log in with twitter you can say
yes i would actually like to make
strange loop greetings six times an hour
for the end of like until the end of
time or maybe just once a year or once
an hour or once a day um and in fact if
somebody replies to me with the word
strange loop
i want to give them like a suggestion of
a talk that they might want to go to so
you can have like uh with no programming
other than making your json object you
can have a functioning twitter bot
uh and roughly sixteen thousand people
have made or well sixteen thousand
twitter bots by the last count which was
like two years ago on that site so lots
of people like picked up that
this is one that i made this is lost
tesla um this is based on an elon musk
tweet about your tesla coming to you
even if it's uh if it's summoned even if
it's across the country and i was on a
road trip at the time and so i thought
about kind of the phenomenology of like
this
robot with wheels and its very small
array of sensors like trying to navigate
across america and make sense of what it
saw
and so this is something where i just
post multiple times a day about kind of
things that it's seeing on its road trip
and i really like this was one of my
first spots that really turned into
poetry um because it's a contrast free
grammar and so it's just like smashing
things together but sometimes it doesn't
realize that it's repeating things
and so i leave a quiet town
now a silo a silo a silo the sun is gone
now everything is gold my sensors detect
light so that's just a poem from a robot
that's a poem from an angle an
accidental language that i made that's
running in a program that i wrote on
some software from someone in london
but there's a lot of these it kind of
like felt like poetry to me these are a
couple of my favorites
um and yeah as i mentioned before
everybody started making these really
wonderful bots
so these are just a couple of the
examples
over on the right are mostly like bots
that people have made
on cheap bots done quick but i had also
released it as a javascript library and
it started also getting ported to a
bunch of other languages so people
started using it for all sorts of
different things
you can write programs that use it for a
variety of different artistic or
non-artistic purposes
as long as you just you know you have
some grammar that you think is going to
generate text without using a lot of
context
and you just kind of want a a faucet of
sad car poetry that you would like to
run forever so do you want a faucet of
sad card poetry then tracery is for you
the user started inventing all sorts of
cool stuff so this is a fun thing that
happens when you get more users
users will start talking to each other
so there's like a sort of network effect
where users will come up with
interesting techniques and show them to
other users so they started making like
cool ascii
uh emoji art um that one person made
some and then everybody else started
like making interesting variations on it
this was one of the most impressive ones
somebody realized that hey you know
what's text
svg
and so he started using tracery to
generate svg art
and v buck and ham edited cheatbox
tongue quick to also have like a
headless phantom thing so it could
render svg and then paste that up there
um so now you can like make these cool
svg artworks uh the the second one on
the right is one that i made called um
everyone's an ai if you're an ai2 it's a
fan uh fanbot for a project that i like
and this is using quick draw data so i
actually turned i took quick draw data
from google which is human drawn images
turned that into a giant grammar and
then uploaded the giant grammar to
cheatbots done quick
so there's a lot of invention going on
people also figured out that hey you
know what what is also hierarchical text
code of course svg is code but like you
can do all kinds of weird code tricks
and so there's a lot of people doing
sort of languages that feed into other
languages using tracery to generate
scripts in other languages so it's
tracer is in fact uh dj to club in
england
because somebody had an audio visual
programming language that they were
making like cool club visuals and if
anybody has ever been to an algorithm
algorithm kind of stuff
and he used tracery to basically make
components that could be mashed up in
real time
and kind of surprise him with how
they're put together
and then of course what's also
hierarchical text tracer grammars
themselves you can make a tracery
grammar that generates tracery grammars
this is in fact not useful for a lot of
things but um i made this thing called
campbell max with it um let's see do i
have an image yeah so these are a couple
of languages
so you can go to canva max it's still up
and you can just like hit the refresh
button too
what it does is it generates um
syllables and constructions for words
and a very simple grammar for how those
words are put together into sentences
so you have kind of like a little
generative logic for how this tiny
language
could exist it uses that generative
model to create a name for this country
and then create a number of sort of
songs or poems for that country
so these are different songs of liz's
for for example
people picked that up uh in a really
beautiful way as they started doing
readings of these uh these languages so
i brought this to an open mic night and
i read a poem very badly and then
somebody who actually like specializes
in reading poetry read it just so
beautifully
and so beautifully that i actually named
the
the project camp events after that
language that existed for only
they they rolled the language the poems
existed
then they refreshed the page and the
language was gone so this is a language
that existed only for a fraction of a
moment and all we have left is the the
memory of what this language was named
so i really like that sort of
ephemerality
so yeah tracery itself been used by lots
of folks i have a site called
artbot.club if you want to make bots
i'm trying to make it into a social
network for bot making but it's it turns
out it's hard to make software i don't
know if y'all knew this
but you can at least go to artbot.club
and you can like it's a pretty posh
editor for editing tracery grammars and
you can earn merit badges see me for
your merit badges
all right well that was great i
accidentally made a programming language
to get out of doing a very small class
assignment for which i got 110
um what about second bug free
programming language
um so then i started like working on
more programming languages the biggest
one that i've gotten some funding for
and to the shame of getting that funding
have not actually finished shipping
but google did i worked on it with
google for a while
as a prototyping platform for the google
assistant and they were kind enough to
open source it so you can search for
battery google and find find some links
to kind of this version on the bottom
right
and this is a chat app about um you
having a kitten and it's kind of like
tracery for finite state machines
unfortunately it's just a little too
complicated for the same sort of like
sixteen thousand third graders uh to use
so that was a that was a disappointment
it turns out that like i couldn't model
that so clearly in my mind that i could
explain it to a third grader
and it's kind of sometimes harder to set
out to write a programming language than
to just accidentally do it
but and this is what this talk is about
today you can accidentally have many
deep thoughts about programming
languages
especially if you're not formally
trained and everything that sounds like
a really deep thought
so part two what is a language
um so i'm really i didn't i dropped out
of cs in college i never had a useful
like programming languages class to tell
me actually what is a programming
language and i i have some very earnest
programming languages friends who are
happy to tell me what a programming
language is
um
but i i also follow this thing called
prototype theory so there's like this
kind of idea of
if you ever get into a conversation
where you're like is this an x or is
this not an x and you're trying to put
the world into buckets so these are
there's a bucket called programming
languages and everything is either
inside or outside of that bucket those
are good conversations to have over beer
and like fun to argue with people online
but they're wildly unproductive
there's a really fun trick that i found
that's called prototype theory which
says that like things are not in or out
of a bucket they're only
there is some prototypical example that
you have in your mind and things are
either far or close from that so it's
like okay java is a programming language
things are either far or close from java
and our programming language based on
that distance
or maybe you have a couple of landmarks
so these are some things that are very
sharing less share things that are not
functional as chairs things that are
obviously not chairs but can function as
chairs so that's kind of like you're
using a lens on things like is it useful
in this moment in this context to think
about this thing as a chair
um so it allows you to ask like useful
stuff like you know if this is a
programming language like what would the
reserved keywords be in this language
you know who is compiling or
interpreting this language um are there
different targets that i'm compiling
this to is this a different language if
i send it to different targets
um and so there's a lot of formal
properties you can say about languages
and i'm not going to talk about those
today who who here knows like formal
properties of languages
all right fewer people than i actually
expected for this conference
but you know that's not my problem today
um you can do really amazing things with
formal project logic i program logic and
i don't have the access to those tools
um and we could also say things like
okay you know
we could fill in this this grid of um
what are the like structure rebel target
rebel programming languages what are the
like purest programming languages and we
kind of like put programming languages
there
um but i kind of really like just kind
of thinking about this through the lens
of you know who's programming this um is
the syntax even words what what is my
syntax in this language like what kind
of thing is being described by these
programs is it like everything in the
world like what is java trying to
describe to us
it's trying to describe a particular
form of very highly structured world um
ideally where the world breaks down into
classes fairly quickly
and then like
is this like is this a form is it kind
of a platform or am i composing things
or am i transforming things like what is
going on in this language what are my
kind of unit operations
um and so as i'm teaching so i teach
intro programming which is super
like i'm learning a ton hopefully the
students are as well but that seems like
a side effect um i'm learning a lot
about kind of like how i think about
programming and i've realized so i'm a
big fan of this book over here the
programmer's brain where it talks about
like the cognitive science of
programming like okay you have a program
and your human brain is actually very
small you have like very small working
memory you have like slightly larger
short-term memory and then you have
quite large long-term memory but it's
impossible to get anything out of there
so how do you fit like a thousand line
program into your brain
much less like a ten thousand line for a
crime or a million line program our 10
million line program like how do you how
do you fit that in your brain and i
often have to talk to students about
like they're feeling like you know
they're looking at their first 15 line
program and thinking i can't fit this
all in my brain i must get a bigger
brain i say no that's not what we do as
programmers we all have tiny brains and
we have tiny brains when we get stressed
this is fine um we need actually these
like cognitive tools to compress the
world that we're thinking about into
things that we can say like
all right that 15 lines that is a loop
that sets this variable or by the end of
this loop i should find uh the student
who's traveled the further south or by
the end of by the end of this function i
should have ordered a coffee and i can
like even if that's like a 50 line
program to order coffee i can kind of
compress that in my head to like okay
this is just a single thing in my brain
now that is like i have the ability to
order coffee if i call this function
they're just cognitive tools to
make your tiny stupid bag of meat able
to comprehend fast universes which is a
neat trick
so yeah um general purpose programming
languages are really neat because um
if you think about it you're saying like
okay here's a general purpose
programming language i have java here
i've told myself that java can
hold anything in the universe it's
general purpose if if the thing exists
in the universe or my imagination i
should be able to somehow fit that into
java
um
and often like
huh
yep um so there's no truly general
purpose programming language but you
know there are things that try to be
more or less general um but we're
building a language to describe the
world so the things that like you know i
use to describe programs to my students
are actually like we think about like
okay you know i've broken this this room
up into here's a speaker over here
that's a special kind of object there's
a whole bunch of chairs maybe i don't
want to think about each individual
chair like my brain just can't process
there are a lot of chairs um or like
each individual chair is like molecules
and so my brain compresses them to okay
there's a bunch of chairs some number of
those chairs are filled with people
those people kind of fill this range of
expectation
and i can like give this talk while
cognitively like turning y'all into
a kind of understandable space in my
head and so like i really like thinking
about like what are these like
loops and if statements and functions
and classes actually doing for us
cognitively that we wanted to do in the
real world or maybe we have other ways
to do in the real world
um so yeah there's two ways to fit a
program into your head um you could have
a smaller program i guess the third way
is to have a very cognitively compressed
program
you can have a smaller program or you
can have a smaller reality this also
works where you're not trying to
describe everything
you maybe need a smaller set of
cognitive tools maybe some tools are not
no longer appropriate or necessary for
this task
so this is when we get into things like
domain-specific languages there's also a
concept that i really like called little
languages that was defined by this
article in i want to say like 89 or so
um it's basically somebody saying like
okay we have these big languages but we
also have these like little we languages
that are often like you have a ui that
outputs this language
or you have just a tiny language that
makes that is like input for other
programs so think of all the times that
you have written a regular expression
inside of another language so these are
kind of like little microscopic
languages that often embed themselves in
larger situations you can have like
languages embedded in languages and the
smaller they are the more happy they are
to do that uh treasury has in fact
become a very good little language um
it's like there's no
it's got no requirements it's got no
like expensive build process it's just
like literally just a scrap of
javascript and so people put it all over
the place so it's easy to just like kind
of i made a version of tracery that fits
in a tweet if you need a tweet length
tracery um you can just kind of tuck it
anywhere
it's a very polite companion
um so yeah it's kind of neat to think
about like what is this programming
language about like what is it to know
something about this world that we're
describing um what cognitive tools do we
need to make sense of this world what
parts of the world are fixed and what
parts of this world exist only in
runtime
um and then the other question we can
also ask about like a world is like okay
what would the programming language
about this domain be like how would we
describe this particular world of like
you know what's the programming language
for coffee like what are the unit
operations on coffee how would you make
a programming language that like
greater than anything else describes
what you believe is important about
coffee it's the morning we all have our
coffee
so yeah here's an example of a
programming language
who here sees the program in this
yeah one person so this is a language
called inform seven um this is for doing
interactive narrative and it was
targeted at writers um thing that i
found with tracery is even the people so
i have one user who made over 100 bots
they're by far my most prolific and
famous user
they have said multiple times i am not a
coder
they won't use the raw json editor they
actually only use the the visual editor
because if they see like a
a crash or a semicolon they're like aha
programmer crap not for me
uh and they know about and i've seen
that like strikingly often in users this
is a really neat thing it's like there's
there's no convincing that i need to do
to like all the people the internet of
like no no semicolons aren't scary um
json is not scary it is um and so this
was a language that was developed for
writers and you can see there's no scary
bits in here but this is a running
program because what inform 7 wants to
describe about the world is it's kind of
like for zerk likes if anybody played
zork in the way back days
like there are rooms there are things in
the rooms you can interact with those
rooms there are things which are said um
think things in this world are described
by the sort of output that they make if
you look at them um there's no like
model for this thing it's just like this
thing like this room exists as a bag of
ways to uh describe this
and so you can do things like say
the apple is a room a winding street in
rome with monkeys ella bloom and salmon
made of chrome so that's a string that
will be described if you like ask about
the apple
the window is a door
the window is east of the apple the
window is west of the lake the lady is
wearing a chapel it looks like a
venomous snake so this is all like valid
syntax to describe a world in the way
that they need to describe worlds
and also i just think it's just
fantastic i won't read the whole thing
but like there's a couple of other
examples of inform 7 program at
poetry at that link
this is just some more tracery you know
tracery what it's about fundamentally is
just things are made out of other things
so it's a context-free grammar but that
those things are kind of like embedded
in a bunch of text
and so it's like text and some stuff
that goes out and text and some stuff
that goes out and so your world is kind
of made of things that need to expand
and things that don't need to expand and
then like ways that you would use
language as a human um so it's kind of
very similar to like a markdown language
in that way where it's uh natural
language and syntax are kind of playing
on an even feel because this thing is
about natural language more than it's
about sort of rigorous structure or
programming
um this is another language that i've
gotten to play around with in the past
this is called answer set solving or
answer set programming
it's kind of like a big like a bigger
prologue
that can do more powerful things this is
me attempting to encode what a murder
mystery is
uh so i have to say like okay so it's
it's a general purpose programming
language originally i think made to do
mathematical proofs um let's get it to
generate a murder mystery and so i can
say things like okay they're in a murder
mystery some number of people are dead
at the end this is true of murder
mysteries uh some number of people are
in love
if you are in love with somebody else
this is what a love triangle is if you
are in a love triangle then you hate
someone
if you hate someone you have a motive
for murder
and so this is like describing a world
and like it's really fun to see the bugs
in this because there are failures to
describe parts of the world that i
didn't know i had to describe so
somebody would attempt to kill
themselves because they were in the love
so they loved themselves and they loved
themselves but they also loved
themselves and so they were very mad at
themselves and they were going to off
themselves
[Music]
radical self-love
so yeah there was a really great talk on
this at uh at strange loop or strangely
for possible like a spin-off conference
um lambda jam i guess anyway it's on the
strange loop uh video site uh which i've
been like watching lots of videos to
prep for this talk uh this is about
musical composition and like describing
music as
a language of composition it's like you
could describe music if you're sort of
naive as like okay here's a sequence of
notes and actually this is like works
perfectly well as like a midi
description language like okay music is
a sequence of notes the notes can be
different pitches this encodes a space
that has lots of very bad music
or it's very hard to kind of like find
any point in that space and say like
okay this is probably music this is
probably not music
and so he thought to himself like okay
okay how would i as a musician describe
music and he describes it as a
functional programming language
where motifs are generated and then
processed and
looped over and transformed and looped
over again and
convoluted in exciting new ways and
combined with each other in exciting new
ways it's a it's a
functional language we had this really
great quote that like i think was just
kind of tossed off as he was talking of
the basic tenet of domain driven
language is that a small change in
domain terms should be a small change in
code terms uh this kind of reminded me
of the allen k thing of simple things
should be simple and complex things
should be possible this idea that like
you know okay here's
what is the definition of a programming
language that matters to me as an artist
it's like okay
i can
small language like small things in my
mind are small programs complicated
things in my mind are complicated
programs programs that are kind of close
to each other should be related um and i
could say like if i have a program here
then a lot of the programs around it
should be related and this is a distance
kind of measured by things that matter
to me
so if you're familiar with vector
encodings is that the idea that you can
take a bunch of information that is not
spatially located and you can say like
okay it's not spatially located but you
do have distances between it
so i can say okay like i've got the
meaning of uh dog and puppy and i think
that those should be very close together
and poppy is actually quite different
from either puppy or dog it should be
quite far away so i can like spatially
arrange these things in some
n-dimensional cube and then you get a
vector encoding out of that and you end
up getting actually quite different
embeddings if you're looking at
different information like different
there's a different thing that you care
about so maybe dog and puppy shouldn't
be close together in pronunciation
encodings poppy and puppy should be
close together and dig and dogs should
be close together
allison parish has a lot of really good
presentations on this where she she
figures out the
the space in between puppy and kitty the
vector interpolation of those two is
committee
so that is like the relationship in this
world where we care about pronunciation
but not meaning
um so it's all about kind of context
there's no like write in coding
so yeah um
i kind of already talked about domain
specific in little languages so i'll
just skip that
so yeah here is uh a couple of different
domain specific languages to express
music
um
if you were a child in preschool you may
have seen both of these at some point
and so they're both different encodings
and you can kind of think about like
okay
um
you know what is what is actually being
encoded here like this is a lot like
mary had a little lamb is a phenomenon
that exists in the world
um it's not obligated to us to be
representable in
in code in any way but we're going to
still try to take a snapshot of it and
put in code um so the one on the left
says like okay the the important things
about this are like uh how long each
note lasts
and how many notes are kind of in a
rhythmic section
and also you know like what is the key
of this
the one on the right says uh i don't
actually think those are relevant to the
user i'm going to drop those dimensions
from my vector encoding space i'm just
like not going to have those in my
language because i don't think they're
relevant to this four-year-old who's
trying to play a piano
all i care about is you know there is an
encoding that says like this key maps to
this letter and this is where you would
put your fingers and so i'm going to
like but you also still need to have the
lyrics so they could have this without
the lyrics but the lyrics are important
to this kid so it's like defining a
programming language or defining an
encoding is like declaring what you
think is important to this user in this
context
this gets really interesting when you
look at other musical encodings so this
is oh i
i must have covered up the uh this is um
tibetan gang chants um so this is
tibetan chanting music um from uh i
think the library in london um and this
is like an encoding of like what's
important about that music and i
certainly don't read any of this but you
can see that it's definitely a different
thing that is available like a different
kind of data encoding that is available
to you in mary had a little lamb
people got really playful with this like
okay how do i encode the things that
matter to me about music
and these are people who are already
like completely expert in musical
notation they could have encoded
anything they want that would fit into
musical notation this was not a
proficiency thing um but somebody like
john cage said okay you know i want to
express my music in a different way
there's a different encoding that i
think is going to be more concise
um i'm i'm you know to pander to this
crowd i've been programming in java too
long and i want to program this in
haskell because i think i can be that
much more elegant in it
so he encoded this in kind of a drawing
um it's called aria you can actually see
people perform this which is like a trip
because it's really interesting to see
okay here's the program what are the
different ways that that program has
been interpreted by different kind of
hardware that it's running on
this is another one i'm a particular fan
of grapefruit by yoko ono so this is a a
score for voice piece for soprano um and
like what is encoded here it's like the
directionality uh you're screaming so
she's encoding like what you're doing
and like a little suggestion of that but
it's like you never see in music like
what am i like is the assumption that
i'm just like projecting to kind of
nowheresville am i recording an album am
i recording or am i playing to an
audience um am i playing for myself
she's like no the important thing about
this piece is where you are directing
your voice
so just kind of a different sort of
highly compressed score
this is a project that was actually made
using tracery by emma winston
this is kind of riffing off of some of
those graphical
music languages
it's called graphical scores and
she would actually like generate these
using tracery and then play these in a
gallery setting
so a little bit more about cool
encodings
these are some neat encodings can
anybody figure out what these are
dance steps yeah these are these are
court dances of the 18th century um
where what do you care about in dance
like if you do different kinds of dance
so i do i used to do swing dancing and
ballroom dancing
and swing dancing was all about the kind
of force that you're applying to the
other person and the like physical
forces that are applying to you at any
given moment
you know are you extended are you
compressing
are you pulling past them
are you like pressing hands to push away
um so i would draw a very different
language for that
these are court dances where there's not
it's not about momentum this is about
precisely moving it through a space and
precisely moving your arms in a space
um and they even have like a little like
composable language for that
and i kind of like that like we can also
look at these as a programming language
using these same tools like saying like
okay you know a small change in domain
term should be a small change in code
terms so if i wanted to like add a step
i should be able to encode that
reasonably in these things without
rewriting the whole program um simple
things should be simple simple things in
this court dance might not be things
that i would think are simple um but
they might be like kind of obvious to
them like what is the what is the
simplicity in this space
so these images are from a book called
choreographics
which is by ann hutchinson
and she worked with one of the earlier
notations and i realized as i was making
this i think her dress is also labon
notation so that's a program over there
over on the left so i i appreciate
somebody being on their bowl about as
much as i usually am
and this is uh what's called lava
notation i'm not an expert in it by any
means um but we had oh no i didn't put
your name in here um mariel uh
from yesterday who gave the deeply
amazing uh talk on dance she also had
lava notation in her slides so this is
second second lava notation in this so
as far as i can tell not being able to
read a lot of notation um it was
described as the dance of the little
swans and then i was able to find a
video of the dance of the little swan so
i think this is like somehow kind of
about encoding uh that space so that
kind of mo that kind of movement of like
you know i have a bunch of people doing
this thing is encoded somehow in that
lava notation is super cool because it's
like a compositional language to
describe dance this is a language to
describe a a space and they still have
to like they still have to make simple
things simple and complicated things
possible because you might have a
choreographer who just like needs to do
some really wild stuff
and so you need to have a language where
you can like compose interesting pieces
together and kind of make new pieces on
the fly if you want to say like okay
like
right arm out but more right arm out but
like you know with an aggressive gesture
and you could kind of like in some way
visually annotate that you can kind of
extend this language as you need to
um things to notice about this diagram
is um vertical movements are uh so
everything is
shapes and so vertical things are
rectangles and then things to the side
are arrows
and things upwards are
shaded and things downward are
solid color
so yeah i figure let's we've got a few
moments here let's learn some wobble
notation and do a quick stretch
um so yeah all right everybody get
limber we're just gonna do a little bit
of physical movement so this is this is
all that you need to know we've got all
right side low black rectangle black
arrow goes down side middle the the
thing with the dot
yeah there you go side high
there you go and then
vertical column hi all right let's try
this out
all right how about that it goes down
into the or
yeah there we go it's reversed on me uh
so yeah dark goes down
all right how about that
there we go right into the middle
all right this is let's see
up and then
vertical
this is the other one to the sides there
we go
all right so we got we haven't seen the
symbol yet but can you guess what the
black rectangle means remember black is
down and vertical so you got that you
got that and that
we go
all right so that one
then that one
it's hard to do this all right and
last pair so we got a
that
and then we've got a
that
oh that
okay here what about a weird one
yeah kind of kind of kind of dabbing
all right one last one just to cement it
and yeah yeah there we go
congratulations you just spelled out
strange loop in stem
before so we can see languages
translating into languages uh so yeah
this was all done by the dance notation
board a group of people who basically
sat around together and said like what
is there
what is there and how can we write it
down which i think just a wonderful
philosophical exercise to do so part
three just the time i've got left
ways of knowing how do we know things
and why is it fun to know things like
why is it fun to discover new things i
was a grad student for 10 years so you
can imagine like exactly how much i
enjoy knowing things and figuring out
new things and i suspect i will just
despite having gotten my degree be a
grad student for life
so like we said before languages have a
bucket of cognitive tools
and we extend those cognitive tools
as we need to as we get to more specific
use cases so you can do the same thing
with developing a language in general
this is often called ontology ontology
is the practice of saying what there is
in the world and how it's structured
these are images from a really good book
called the book of trees which is a
history of tree diagrams throughout
history
and there's things like you know
religious texts and the one in the
center is uh railroad
railroads leaving from new york city so
that's new york city in the bottom and
the like tree of all the places that you
can get to know from new york city and
where you would like how they branch out
from that tree
um so there's a lot of kind of
mind-expanding tree diagrams in that but
this is just like one way of saying like
oh i think
like of all the things that i could say
about railroads the most important thing
i could say about railroads is what is
their path back to new york city um you
know or what is the like you know of all
the things i could say about like the
plant hedge nets like the most important
thing is which one descended from which
other one or you know nature photography
i really want to say like what kinds of
nature photography are in which other
kinds of buckets like there's no there's
no reason that nature photography as a
phenomena needs to fit into a diagram
we're kind of sketching a diagram that
says like this is what's important to me
right now
um so
ontologies are always imperfect and
they're always kind of contextual like
what's important to us right now
uh it's it's a tool that we work on it's
it's not you can definitely have an
ontology that's like baked into
wikipedia or an ontology that's baked
out to a dictionary but often they're
just like a thing that we're figuring
out on the fly
um how do we build an ontology well you
have a workshop with a bunch of people
this is a stock photo of a workshop that
looks just like awful and i thought i
would put that in but you can also have
the one on the left where it's just a
group of people asking themselves what
is there
um surprisingly this is fun or at least
it's fun to assure to people that this
is fun to there's a tautology for you um
i actually during the pandemic started
hosting what i call evenings of
recreational ontology
if y'all has anybody in here experienced
a
google doc party or google sheets party
all right so google sheets party there's
a great article on medium about these by
mary folstein who is one of the first
people who threw one these are you get a
bunch of people on zoom you make a
google sheet and people just start
filling in the cells however they want
and they make like pixel art um often
you make like a page that's called
kitchen and people start like dropping
food emoji in and like talking about how
delicious the cake is and it's basically
pandemic people going absolutely mad
and enjoying kind of this sort of social
activity um but we started using it in
my research group that was like meeting
online uh to do like
we started actually this was somebody's
birthday uh uh spreadsheet party in the
top here um and somebody made the like
list of all the things that there are
um so we had one page of the spreadsheet
that was to list all the things that
there are and what we know about all the
things that there are and they started
making things like okay well what object
is there uh what size is it what is the
age is it opaque is it hot or not um and
you know trying to answer things like
that things for things like a thousand
years
um skimble shanks emily bronte the
opacity spreadsheet column um a block of
gruyere and just kind of like coming up
with ridiculous answers for each of
these as like a fun thing to do at a
party this is like jack box for extreme
nerds
um
but it's also like really useful to like
solve this problem of like what is there
to get a bunch of people together and be
like and so i've had these things i've
done them for um
using tarot and procedural content
generation so there's a bunch of us who
like do who are really into tarot and
are also really into games and
procedural content generation um and so
we we had one that was just like okay
what are all the different ways that
like
generativity and tarot have gone
together physically or digitally in the
past or in the future uh let us list all
the things that there are um i did one
for uh like um kind of procedural
content generation getting used in games
like what or the pleasures of procedural
content generation like why is it fun to
use
generators like when when generators
generate weird stuff like when lost
tesla does its thing why is it fun and
so it let us list all the ways that that
could be fun and like kind of start
developing
a tree structure or any kind of
structure even words to describe what's
going on
one of the words that i came up with for
doing an ontology of ontologies is cow
tools
these are imperfect
ontological tools of saying like okay
there's a category of things i have a
bad name for this thing bad names always
stick but like this is a tool that i'm
going to build as like a horrifying
prototype that's going to get me to
where i need to get cognitively
this is
there's a thing about prototypes this is
from a talk from heim gingal who uh was
the main prototyper on spore if anybody
played spore back in the day um i got to
work with him a bit on that he's just a
brilliant thinker but his talk was about
how okay prototyping we all know what
prototypes are
they're little crappy software
but like what are they really
um and so he he thought okay prototypes
are actually there to answer a question
you don't build a small prototype
because you want to build a small thing
you want to build a miniature version of
your software before you build the big
version of your software that's not what
they are what they are is you say like
okay can react actually do this
if i build this thing in webrtc is it
going to crash when it gets onto a
campus network
yes um
so your answer you're like will the user
even enjoy pushing this button like in
in the smallest version of this world
can i make a button that the user wishes
to press even though there's not like
all the server architecture that might
make them wish to press that button so
you're answering a small question then
throwing that away it's very much a cow
tool this is a thing that should be
weird and awkward and alien and that's
okay
mostly i just like making y'all look at
that comic
um this is another one a cow tool that i
came up with that like ended up sticking
was this is a phrase from our like
ontology jam
how do people understand things and i
came up with the awkward term of fitting
an octopus into an ontology
so everybody do this quick exercise look
at the people on either side of you
one of them is haskell one of them is
the javascript
and one of them is the fortran and if
neither on no one on either side of you
is the fortran then it's you
[Laughter]
so yeah this is the the idea behind
fitting an octopus into an alter
ontology is the idea that it's kind of
fun to have a broken tool and try to
map our world onto a tool that it
clearly doesn't want to fit into uh
you're trying to fit an octopus into an
ontology like what like octopi don't
want to fit anywhere that they don't
want to fit uh but like it's just hard
to categorize this thing but it's fun to
do so
um and so you get you end up getting
these sorts of situations where you have
like these these quizzes of like oh well
which platonic solid are you like you
have to fit yourself into one of these
platonic solids
which one do you feel you most identify
with and there's a bunch of fun variants
on those and we'll often kind of start
fitting ourselves in this you can also
have ontologies that like in the diagram
of strange to loop did any of you start
immediately trying to figure out where
the talks that you had seen or where
your talk was going to fit on the the
strange to loop diagram
and did you start wondering like well
okay what's in the like farthest right
corner what's in like what is is there a
talk that is the least strange and least
loop at this conference
uh hopefully
not um and then you can also have things
where like the existence of an empty
bucket encourages you to fill it in and
then even if there's not anything that
really fits in there you have to say
well why isn't there anything that fits
in there see we're we're understanding
the world by an imperfect tool that's
not working
um so yeah this is fun for lots of
reasons i want to just kind of skip to
the end i'm almost there
so my dissertation that i spent 10 years
on is on casual creators this is how to
get casual people to be creative so if
you've ever played like jack box games
through friends or pictionary
um or like even spirographs of just like
okay here's a here's a device that is
like allowing me to be imperfectly
creative but supporting me in some ai
way so i did a ton of research on like
why those things work and often they are
like it's because you don't have to do
as much heavy lifting you don't have to
make as many choices the choices you're
going to make are going to be awkward in
some way but that's actually like if you
design it well that's some of the fun
um there's a bunch of other tools that
are available to you so this is uh
there's things like community tagging
card sorting a lot of these get used in
sort of like normal
daily ontology of like what is our
website well i think that our website is
you know a help page and the like setup
page and this we actually did this
exercise in the documentation thing is
like uh in the documentation tutorial
that was on thursday like what is this
website hear a bunch of things figure
out the ontology that makes this make
sense and it's going to have to be
imperfect because every ontology is and
every oncology is going to have to say
like well
this is the way that this website ought
to be for a user who's confused and has
a question this is the way the website
has ought to be for you know this is the
ontology that makes sense if you're
trying to contribute to this thing if
you're trying to contribute to this open
source project my ontology of the world
is going to be wildly different
um you also have things like
folksonomies
um i think probably the greatest like
there's wikipedia but my personal
favorite example is ao3 uh if anybody's
into database design or um folksonomy or
once like basically what what wikipedia
could be through the rabbit hole this is
the site where people write fanfic of
different things um and then there's a
massive community tagging organization
all the tags you can scrape all the tags
there's python downloaders for all the
tags so it's just people writing
millions of fan fictions about different
things and then tagging them in
different ways and the tags are all kind
of semantically linked to each other so
this is i tried to find one on
programming languages and here's one
where apparently c is dating javascript
and they're both non-binary
and so yeah so this is them trying to
tag that so you can semantically find
the javascript fanfic that you want
while avoiding the javascript fanfics
that you don't want
um we don't have great tools for
collecting this information aside from
something like 803 we don't have general
purpose things it's just like hey can i
like i would love something where i can
have an ontology gym and we like get to
build trees and the best i've got is
monroe but that doesn't scrape the
information usefully yet so
uh this is like
kind of an open question of doing more
of that
but yeah this kind of idea of like you
know what is it to to build uh you can
to learn things we can build prototypes
and we can build prototype languages um
one of my favorite things when i'm
developing things like chancery is i put
myself in the mind of some an author
who's writing in this and saying like
okay i want something where the world is
ending and there's one state machine
where like
different world ending things are
happening and you hear them on the radio
but also you're wandering around a house
and also you have a relationship with
another person so here are three
different like state machines going and
i'll just start type i will imagine that
somebody has written this programming
language and i will just start typing as
naturally as i can of how i would want
to program that and then i use that to
kind of tell myself what ought to be in
this language
and where it ought to be and like what
is common if i try to write write this
program myself i'll show myself what's
common what's uncommon in in a world
that doesn't exist yet uh you can also
have humans play computers um there's a
book called by phil agree called
computation and human experience where
he talks kind of deeply and into the
philosophic philosophy of building
things to know things he works in ais
it's like
we all think we know something about ai
until we try to build an ai and then we
know
very different things about ai and have
very different questions so building
things is a way to know the world
so last thought before i let y'all go is
we're going to contemplate the universe
and write an api for it not as an
exercise but you know y'all can do this
on your own time
um so i like i really like to draw i
like to watercolor paint i'm like okay
at both of them but it kind of doesn't
matter
because the way that i use these is i i
tend to be very like
a lot of us are like we try to know the
world very rapidly we try to make first
impressions we try to like parse out
things rapidly and this is just like a
thing that humans do to be able to deal
with the world it's like you just say
like okay there's a building there's a
building there's a building there's a
coffee shop i want to go to and you
don't even have to think about those
three buildings that you just passed um
but if you sit down and like do drawing
or painting as a practice you actually
have to like say like gosh there's these
like super weird little finials on top
of this building that i never looked at
like wait no that piece isn't connected
to this other piece like wow like that
stonework is doing some really
complicated stuff with how it's fitted
together you have to like you know if
you do this with nature stuff you're
like oh a nice blue pond full of green
water lilies um dang there's no blue or
green actually anywhere in the scene you
have to like truly look at the scene and
like take some time slow down see beyond
what is expected to be there to what's
really there
um so i think this is a really nice kind
of task of like what if this is a way to
slow down and appreciate and sketch a
domain that you're trying to write a
program for
rather than saying ah i see that you
were attempting to do a coffee shop
maintenance
program like you need to like do
inventory and stuff i see what you need
is like off the shelf number and like
honestly if you just want to get your
work done and like give these people a
nice stable program to work with but
sometimes it's nice to think of like
okay well like i love coffee like what
is it that i love about coffee and how
would i describe that to a computer
so yeah i kind of just like final
thoughts like building languages to me
and i've done a couple of other terrible
languages after tracer and chancery that
like nobody needs to see but they're
just kind of like my sketches of like
this is too
uh like this is a form of poetry for me
writing a writing a program writing a
language
where we're trying to sketch a picture
of some kind of universe that we care
about something that we like actually
want to sit down and look at and maybe
we didn't even care about it before we
started looking at it deeply
but we want to explain it to a computer
so the computer can understand what it
is that we care about um so this
computer and its imperfect silicon brain
can also say yeah no the most important
thing about coffee is the relationship
of like heat to water and how that's
gonna alchemically change the beans and
that that's not a momentary process that
is a continual process over time
um so yeah
uh that is the last slide i have so i'm
just uh
i was kind of rambling but there we go
uh deeply think about the universe and
make an api about it i guess any
questions
yeah the question was how does this work
with gpt3 and how that's going to like
how do how is that going to store its
information
gpg3 and like other other neural nets
are really interesting because they too
have cognitive tools that they use right
so you have these middle layers these uh
this latent space where if i want to
auto encode something i take my object i
try to
fiddle with these weights such that the
object goes in
it compresses down to a much smaller
space than it was once was and then it
compresses back out and it's like mostly
lossy so it's like what is the latent
space that is like lossiest to the
things i care about this in this image
like what is what is this neural network
encoding of this image that like most
captures the things i care about so it's
like useful to me as a cognitive tool in
that way of like
okay this is a way that i could get a
computer to be my partner in an ontology
jam like why don't you tell me what you
think is important from what i've told
you
um it's also a kind of a target of
ontology like what what do we think is
happening in this ai and we don't yet
have the cognitive tools to even be
labeling a lot of stuff yet so we we are
short on cow tools for machine learning
um like we don't even have poor tools
yet to start understanding what's going
in like we have very rudimentary cow
tools right now where it's just like
okay we can do some like deep dream
stuff to like try to show ourselves
what's going on in these middle layers
um but we don't yet have
the language that we can use to
interpret in the same way that we have
like you know i can look at a program
and be like okay there's a for loop and
there's a class and there's a an if
statement and there's a while loop and i
can understand like i can fit that into
my head i don't have any of those
cognitive tools to parse this kind of
massive soup of weights
oh yeah
thank you thank you all
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you